okay looks like we're back looks like
we're back with episode guy [ __ ] gets
viral and I am I'm handsome so let's do
this
great the crickets are back Oh course
not
okay close up what so here's a lot Oh
Bethany mmm good girl good girl
gara the car is good go you stop ready
kick your others calories and I was not
hey girl oh wait so we did ignore the
fact that our brothers I got a lemon
honey or something I wish you to go
relax I'll take them Thanks thanks guy
man Ron Howard director this like what's
up with all the actors like they're
horrible I would knock what side night
okay Abbi I guess I just I don't need to
believe anymore
what's the point of believing in
anything people are getting killed lovin
right I just I wish I could understand
why okay okay I like this nightmare and
what what's going on what happened back
there tell her everything okay creep leo
what did you say again something about
going viral
Abbi Leo work for guy host
[ __ ] okay we have to go now come on
oh my god DC house he threw the
cigarette on mother earth that is
disgusting that's the real are what is
going on took you so long
that [ __ ] Abby look what she did to my
phone
I want her day you need to keep him
alive for launch
wow this is not only the worst hiding
spot I've ever seen like murder this
door Elias now I've gotten pretty bad
and run our to that directly like thank
God anyway it's like help my name is
only attach it too much shut the power
up bro a guy like really pretty for days
what I use only their like a single
power station like upstairs revivalist
drunk girls in the cold this is like the
cheesiest ever saying this is like a
skinemax I murdered in the first place
and intimate sex is drug and all that
some people are the kind of sacrifice
that societies or what we wanted to
what brow I cut the power the pump right
what is going on here
this is cash a walk outside
hey I shoot back her head
it's the cult first like the showrunners
you should go
hell yeah we should go go Denny yeah
anyone up for Denny's of an angry
and Wow
okay that was a they series is over but
that was us of all that was so bad oh my
god like the first episode seemed so
promising and then he said the writers
just got lost
oh that was horrible I'm sorry you had
to watch this if you got to this episode
you literally wasted like 15 mins your
life oh sorry guys that was horrible